oh captain holt is here today yes genius
he loves us and he's got tons of sway in
the department he'll tell the vulture to
back down yeah he'll be all vulture i
must insist that you desist i really
think this is going to work
also if you ever want to bust out that
whole impression at home i'd be okay
with that oh
okay duly noted super disturbing but i'm
definitely gonna do it
my cover makes me invisible
excuse me ma'am do you have two minutes
to talk about the environment nailed it
now no one will make eye contact with me
i think it's cute you're like an
idealistic grad student oh you like that
you want me to tell you about the time
that i backpacked through the
netherlands ooh did you fold all your
stuff up really small to fit into one
carry-on is that what you want me to
have done so you approach on foot from
the south and me and devin will be in an
unmarked car here whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
me and devin didn't you mean
devin and i oh god i corrected your
grammar are you so proud of me are you
horrified are you super horny we need to
woo them
with the international language of
friendship
pork
oh i'll take it to them it's all dudes
down there and i'm not above using
little flirtation to get what i want
was that a wink you tell me
i honestly don't know but you're all we
got
[Music]
hello boys
oh wait wait i i winked my contact out i
don't know it's still there oh god it's
behind my eye
i love paperwork but this is crazy there
isn't even time to savor it
charles you're going so fast i don't
have a choice we can't let this place
fill us with perps yeah but you're gonna
cramp
you kidding baby i've been cramping for
the past 20 minutes
i'm so attracted to you right now
yeah that wasn't a fight that was just
sexy workplace banter exactly i mean
mattresses are also sexy cause that's
where you do it yeah and grammar is a
system of language involving syntax and
semantics
also sexy
okay okay okay okay or drink amy is a
bit of a pervert okay check it out
[Music]
what are you wearing
a t-shirt
i only brought a bikini it seems weird
to be in front of the captain of bathing
suit gotta cover up them fangs yeah
fyi you can still see them for your
shirt here's the plan the boring holt
party will be in the living room at
least three of us must be with him in
that room at all times it's not a party
if there aren't four people especially
between the sheets
all right boyle rosa and amy you're up
come on get on it and under it
bang-a-rang damn sam james
you don't want to be around holt in your
current state
say hello to the most confident woman
alive
uh
drink number five
you are a true friend
and a hot little piece
goodbye forge rank amy
sloppy sicko she poned me i read the
entire urban dictionary so i could
converse with the other uniformed
officers finished it in 47 minutes
i've never been so attracted to a gay
man before and i dated several in
college so we have a read-off santiago
we don't have finger guards so we do it
raw okay i've got something oh that's
not brandon's profile it's mine i just
want a quick peek at your attendance
record zero absences
oh mama printing this for later keep it
in your pants santiago oh that's exactly
where it's going
danny matthews that's the guy he was on
the football team that's the bastard who
set me up yeah and look at this
you did so much community service
me likey all right what i am about to
say will make you very horny but you
have to try and remember that we're
still at work
do you want me to quiz you oh god yes
wow okay great i have an idea of how to
find cheddar amy
don't act weird when i say this but
we're gonna need to use the binder
oh mama i'd like to take you out tonight
for a thank you dinner oh i would love
that but i'm gonna have to take a rain
check cause amy and i already have plans
although i'm pretty sure you would
approve so this is a brine barrel it's
made by josiah wooldriff who learned the
craft from his father jessia wooldriff
who in turn learned you know what this
was a terrible idea i'm sorry don't you
dare stop oh
okay josiah's cousin joshua was a cooper
not a hooper oh mama okay you ready
mm-hmm
hello oh my god
are you melville dewey indeed i am
i invented the dewey decimal system but
right now i'm working on
the doomy decimal system mm-hmm yeah
this is really working for me really
yeah awesome so mr dewey can you save me
from the terrorists that have taken over
nakatomi plaza yes holly gennaro
i just need to file them in the library
card catalog yeah this is really hard to
track let's just take our clothes off oh
thank god this old jacket is so hot yeah
yes okay it's time to celebrate you know
what that means this bee needs a c in
her a oh my god this babe needs a
coconut in her arms oh
i thought you were saying this music oh
my god yeah that was my reaction all
right i'll go get us a couple of
coconuts i present to you a serial arson
case mm-hmm and the fires seem to be
connected to the saturday crossword
puzzle mama like two different buildings
two consecutive saturdays and a puzzle
left at each crime scene and a note was
sent to the puzzle's author mr melvin
sturmly melvin sternly he's the best in
the game he made a puzzle once where all
the answers were just the word puzzle in
different languages in estonian it was
moist status yeah well your moist status
is about to be hecka moist don't call hr
we are getting married because melvin
sturmly is coming in to help us with the
case show wing i was scared in there
with pam too and
you know i didn't panic or mess anything
up there if anything i was sharper and
it was a freaking debate genius debate
genius oh that's very hot oh that's an
added bonus okay keep that energy up
what else oh you're never gonna believe
this i've been reading reading like
books by real authors i don't know is
phillip roth a real author oh
my goodness
i wish you had gone to prison years ago
i'm kidding obviously i'm not more
attracted to you now than before
life is unpredictable
not everything's in our control but as
long as you're with the right people you
can handle anything
and you jake peralta
are the right person for me
but i do have some bad news
there is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt
your butt is the bomb there will be no
survivors attention everyone say goodbye
to the jake peralta you know and love
where today is the day i forever change
ooh are you finally growing a mustache
no you know i can't do that and it's
cruel of you to keep bringing it up you
know what i'm glad we broke the rule and
had sex on the first date me too cause
we're like really good at it so good
right stupid good it makes no sense
we're light and breezy if we want to
break rules break rules like what's
another rule we could break
no making out at work okay
that's very flattering amy but there are
some rules that i shall never let's go
okay
amy where are you at four drinks what's
for drinking at me again why don't you
come over here and find out right horny
amy it feels like you should retire that
one for the meteorology come over here
make me
sorry we couldn't you know save the
precinct nothing to be sorry about
your moral compass is on fire right now
okay forget i said anything this is
better you two have been in this
evidence locker for hey
what nothing oh
what the hell is going on i can't let
you quit yes but why the candles and
rose petals
is that mr mclean i hear cause someone's
about to die oh my god
you